[Music]
how did it feel to be out there show
where your first big performance here at
the building it was intense I can't even
explain to you what was going on in my
head it was like dum tum tum tum tum tum
tum tum and it went by so slow but at
the same time when it was over it felt
like it was like one second long
um but yeah it was definitely I feel
like it's not gonna hit until about an
hour from now I'm gonna be like oh my
god I just perform at the billboards Oh
performer tonight and also so a music
out yeah it's been a really really big
week for me um a lot of like I said like
it's just been really really emotional
for me um in the feedback you've been
getting you know from your fans I know
you thought of me and Nelly your solo
like what what's the buy they've just
they've always been super supportive of
me but I think that they really love
having a tangible just like piece of my
heart you know for them to listen to and
that feels really good cuz I feel like
they've been so loyal and supportive of
me and I just I just want to make them
proud so I'm so happy that they love the
music I want to ask you really quickly
working with Pharrell Williams I mean
that's a hell that's a heck of an
opportunity what was it like it was
amazing and we did a couple songs
together and hopefully you're gonna get
to hear them soon but he's amazing I
can't wait to get back in the studio
with him he's just seeing him be him is
inspiring for any artist
[Music]